algo muy importante porque las
donaciones terminan siendo también un
termómetro de apoyo a los candidatos al
14 de octubre yo vaya en el demócrata ha
recibido mil millones de dólares en
donaciones pequeñas en comparación a los
600 millones de dólares que recibió
donald trump las personas que más han
votado según un estudio que hace
bloomberg y ahora para la campaña
demócrata son trabajadores de silicon
valley y trabajadores que están en
amazon en apple y en google en grandes
cantidades y en pequeñas donaciones en
las páginas web estas personas en
silicon valley apoyaron con su dinero al
demócrata de bailén en lo que tiene que
ver con trump fueron los miembros de la
fuerza pública de los marines los que
más financiaron la campaña republicana
en lo que tiene que ver con los grandes
donantes es sheldon adelson
[Aplausos]
la campaña de 28 35 millones de dólares
financió este señor a don ocho años y
fue michael bloomberg ex alcalde de
nueva york y ex candidato a la
presidencia dueño del medio de
comunicación lo que más sonó para la
campaña de baile total 157
cristóbal para darnos una idea
comparemos la financiación que tuvo byd
en contra la que tuvo trump creo que
está haciendo ruido tu hoja con el
viento este tenemos unos 40 segundos
la financiación de joe by de nuevamente
mil millones de dólares en pequeñas
donaciones en gente que se mete a la
página web y dona la campaña demócrata
en comparación a los 600 millones de
dólares que recibió donald trump es
decir yo bailé en el demócrata recibió
400 millones de dólares más en pequeñas
donaciones y una última cifra antes de
que se nos acabe el tiempo
el promedio de donaciones al demócrata
yo bailé fue de 40 dólares esta cifra
quiere decir que fueron muchas las
personas que votaron t perdón que
donaron a la campaña demócrata y pues
sumó esta gran cifra de mil millones de
dólares algo que refleja el apoyo en
donaciones al partido demócrata